the leader of a nuclear state believes
another nuclear power is about to launch
at them
they decide that a preemptive nuclear
strike is the only option
the killing of millions of foreign
citizens to save their own people
but here's what they might not realize
even if the conflict is confined to just
one region of the globe
no one in the world will escape the
long-term devastation that will soon
follow
in 1945 in hiroshima and nagasaki
the world bore witness to the
devastating effects of nuclear
firestorms and radioactive fallout
but it wasn't until 35 years later that
scientists calculated that something
even more terrifying would happen if a
large-scale nuclear war were to erupt
the smoke and soot lofted into the
stratosphere by nuclear firestorms and
spread around the world by jet streams
would block enough sunlight to create an
artificial winter and decimate
agriculture
earth would cool dramatically
warmed by the sunlighted blocks the
smoke would float like a hot air balloon
far above the rain clouds for months or
years without being rained down
a global nuclear winter
scientists predict that the resulting
famine and civilizational collapse would
kill most people on earth
this is a terrifying expansion of what
we've already known of the horrors of
nuclear conflict
and yet the nuclear winter story is also
one of hope of scientific discovery
collaboration and outreach bringing
about positive political change
a story over many many years of people
from all over the world from different
backgrounds ideologies and disciplines
that allowed the world to see beyond the
mushroom cloud
in 1980 jeannie peterson editor of ambio
magazine commissioned various
investigations into the long-term
environmental effects of a hypothetical
war using half of the u.s and the ussr's
nuclear stockpiles
this included a seminal paper by
atmospheric chemists paul crudson and
john burks who focused on smoke clouds
caused by nuclear firestorms
the magazine revealed for the first time
the climatic effects of a nuclear war
prompting widespread press coverage
and even hearings at the u.s house of
representatives a science team including
richard turco brian tune and carl sagan
took this research further
sagan and tune applied their findings
about the impact of volcanic dust clouds
on earth's climate
and turco who had military research
connections contributed details about
nuclear explosions
their paper coined the term nuclear
winter
in 1983 carl sagan orchestrated two
major conferences in cambridge
massachusetts and washington dc
featuring an unprecedented televised
discussion with soviet scientists who
were studying nuclear winter
[Applause]
independently gyorgy stenchakov was
pivotal in publishing the first
confirmatory soviet reports
extending the american models to include
3d climate modelling and the effects of
the oceans retaining heat it was this
significant bilateral acceptance that
paved the way to help persuade both
cooperative and reagan east and west
that a nuclear war can never be won and
must never be fought
as computers improved so did nuclear
winter modelling turco tune and
stenchikov were soon joined by alan
roebuck and all have kept working in the
field to this day often together
they and collaborators have created
state-of-the-art simulations revealing
that a nuclear winter could last as long
as a decade and that even a regional
nuclear war might damage agriculture
enough to kill billions
for discovering and spreading the word
about nuclear winter and continuing to
research and educate about it we give
these heroes the future of life award
after a reduction of nuclear arsenals at
the end of the cold war nuclear winter
has unfortunately faded from public
consciousness
but by remembering the work of these
pioneering minds we can better inform
future decisions and hold our leaders
accountable
when taken seriously nuclear winter
transforms the entire strategy around
nuclear weapons the notion of mutually
assured destruction mad is blown apart
by the prospect of self-assured
destruction s.a.d
heeding their warning could be the
difference between catastrophe and
flourishing
you